in terms of change you like it did
change your life physically did it yes
it did I know what you mean yeah yeah
okay right so look basically I have
always highly complex with the way I
walk and I've always been told very
every you know point in my life that
I've I'm not going to be told I've got a
bad walk but someone's always commented
on my walk it's always been a bit like
all right but yes I remember mine at
school said because I've quite I'm not
this won't happen but I have quite
pronounced calf muscles hereditary thing
but I remember my mate once we were
talking about it we didn't just sit
right and talk about that he said you
know why because I said no I think it's
good my dad does it's hereditary
he said no no it's cuz you walk in there
tiptoes so I was like it's not a weird
thing whatever anyway a couple of jobs
have done the first day that we did the
fall and I had the walk and the director
or the producer writer Alan Kubek came
up and said is that the character thing
or I could be trying to cover my way out
of it and I thought no I just thought
that is how I walk she started working
things he started talking about why
don't you take maybe take longer strides
honestly and with my wife and I would
walk around where we live in London and
because I'm bad cuz I'm on my tiptoes
I'm quite high on crab buoyancy so my
wife we said one each I'm leaning back
awesome I'm literally walking we're
going for walks and a billet tree so
that I'll show you make this is my old
walk right that is the old walk I'm so
excited
don't get that excited it's my I'm so I
just same guy oh there's my oh boy okay
this is my this is what we tried right
with my wife remember mister saw
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
and then this is what I settled on and
I'll tell you how we got there okay
you'll see anyone I got there was I have
to dance in just a little bit dancing a
52-degree
and that was I can't dance at all so I
mean I they asked me could I dance and I
was like yeah done so I had dance
lessons and it was like Foxtrot was very
classic and the the dance teacher I was
really struggling with it and the dance
teacher said you know what you need to
do just think about it I was walking
[Laughter]
literally the first thing you learn to
do in life you know just think it walk
heel to toe heel to toe
I do have to - like more - I don't know
you know I just apply that every day and
I'm
[Applause]
[Music]
you